SANJAY SARMA: The
person who invents
a new sustainable energy source
or figures out how to remove
plastics from the ocean--
it doesn't matter whether they
have a degree or certificate.
What matters is can they
actually achieve it.
That, I think, is what we
need to keep our eye on, which
is, can they solve the problem?
SARAH HANSEN: Today
on Chalk Radio,
we're sitting down
with Sanjay Sarma,
the Vice President for
Open Learning at MIT.
Sanjay wears many hats.
He's a professor of
mechanical engineering,
a developer, writer,
a parent, and, perhaps
most salient for us at
MIT OpenCourseWare, Sanjay
is a learner.
In today's episode, Sanjay
talks to us about learning,
from the social
systems behind how
we learn to the biology
of how we're wired to make
sense of the world around us.
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen.
In August of 2020, Sanjay
released his book, Grasp:
The Science Transforming How
We Learn, which he co-authored
with Luke Yoquinto.
SANJAY SARMA: It's
about how we learn.
It's an attempt
to describe how we
learn with a biographical
aspect to it.
Some ask me, why
is it called Grasp?
Why Grasp?
Think about it.
In English, when you
really get something,
you call it grasping something.
I think the German
word is similar.
Comprehension-- it has
the word "apprehend."
You apprehend someone.
It's grabbing.
In Hindi, which is one of
the languages I grew up with,
you also use a similar
word, which is--
I really got the concept.
You grab it.
So what does it
really mean to learn?
That's what this book is about.
And what is the
science behind it?
How does curiosity drive it?
What does it mean to
memorize something?
What does it mean
to forget something?
What does it mean when you
actually remember something,
but you can't access it?
But when you get it,
once you've accessed it,
it all comes flowing out.
So that's what
this book is about.
And it tries to map
it from neurons all
the way to a societal level.
SARAH HANSEN: So what prompted
him to write the book?
For Sanjay, it was
about uncovering
the history of
schooling and rethinking
the methods we use to teach.
SANJAY SARMA: I always
wondered why we ended up
doing things the way we do.
And it turns out
that a lot of it
is happenstance, and perhaps
a historical accident.
The impact of what we were
trying to educate people about,
which initially was
religious books--
and eventually, it was
memorizing aspects of the book,
and then it was the
Greek thread that
wove into that, and then
the Industrial Revolution,
and so on.
And so the question was, if
you went back to the basics,
how would you teach and
what would you teach?
I, too, am a product of
Western education principles.
And I did well.
But I also struggled.
And so I started wondering
what the science tells us
about how educational
systems should be designed.
So once I started
researching it,
I thought, oh my god, the
story needs to be told.
So the book started
writing itself.
And then I found Luke.
And he shaped it with me.
And that's what led to Grasp.
SARAH HANSEN: So what's the
difference between simply
picking up concepts and
actually grasping them?
According to Sanjay, what
it often comes down to
is having an
actionable component
to learning, not just hearing
and regurgitating information,
but locking it in place
by physically applying it.
SANJAY SARMA: We
have this assumption
that the learner's mind
is a sheet of paper
and the professor has a
pen and all the professor
has to do is write on the sheet
of paper and declare victory.
And after 10 minutes,
15 minutes, 20 minutes,
if the learner isn't
paying attention,
that's the learner's fault,
not a teacher's fault.
And that is just
fundamentally wrong.
And every parent knows
this, by the way.
When we go to the classroom,
we just ignore that truth.
The fact is the learner is
forming a model of the world.
It's like a plant growing.
You can't give the plant a
lifetime's worth of water
on the first day and
say, you're done,
and all the potassium on day 2
and all the nitrogen on day 3--
can't do that.
The plant wants
water or sunlight
or a particular
type of fertilizer
when the plant wants it.
By the way, that's called
precision agriculture.
It's a field.
But yet we do that
to human beings.
I want to teach you all the
math you need in the first four
months.
You should be done.
That's not how it works.
It's when you use the math
that it becomes valuable.
And every classroom violates it.
Every class violates it.
Curricula violate
that principle.
What marks something
as something
that needs to be
remembered or as valuable?
Well, when you process it.
So if you have a
nice conversation
with your child or your
spouse, you remember that.
But the conversation you
had, quotidian conversation
about something--
don't forget to pay the
bill or something-- yeah,
you'll remember that.
But the conversation
itself isn't memorable.
So engagement and purpose
flag learning for the brain
as being valuable.
And they put it in a sequence
that makes it actionable.
SARAH HANSEN: I've been working
with Sanjay for many years
at MIT Open Learning.
And the phrase that
I hear him utter most
is, how does your idea scale?
I wanted to take
this opportunity
to ask him about his focus
on scaling innovations
in learning.
SANJAY SARMA: There's
something about learning
that is a human evolutionary
aspect of our existence, which
is children learn,
parents teach.
And we keep that.
So as an adult, I
learn in similar ways
to how I learned as a baby
from my parents, as a child,
as a young person.
Parenting is not scalable.
There's a reason we
have fewer children,
but we give them full attention.
So I think our
biggest challenge is
there are lots of people,
lots of young people,
lots of adults in the
world that need to learn.
And the challenge
is, can we scale
what is very hard to scale?
It's sort of of the
most important question.
And we can only do it if we
understand how people learn
and understand how
technology could help
and how humans could help
and how coaching could help.
But the scale of
demand is so vast.
If you want to make an impact,
you've got to figure out,
how do we scale this thing
that is so difficult to scale?
So to me, that's the
existential question.
SARAH HANSEN: One of the
interesting things about Sanjay
is that he's helping solve
this question of scalability
through online learning.
As Sanjay will
explain in a moment,
online learning cuts out
many of the characteristics
of traditional classroom
models, such as one-way lectures
and an emphasis on memorization.
SANJAY SARMA: So imagine
you're in the desert
and you're thirsty.
If I give you a glass of
water which is only half-full,
you're not going to say,
oh my god, it's half-empty.
You're going to
say it's half-full.
So for those who don't
have access to learning,
online education is
a glass half-full.
But it's still water.
For those who can have
residential education,
online learning is
quite something else.
It displaces lecture time and
creates room for doing all
the hands-on stuff that makes
education doubly wonderful--
the curiosity, the coaching,
the field trips and discussions
and disputation, the
fun, the joy of learning,
the-- what I call
the magic of MIT.
And online learning
gets rid of the thing
we waste a lot of time on,
which is one-way lectures.
So to me, online learning has
two very different purposes.
It's a glass half-full for
those who are parched for water.
It's still great water.
So online learning--
it is something
that makes in-person
education much richer,
as well, by leaving time to do
the hands-on stuff that today
is occupied by lectures.
So that's the flipped classroom.
SARAH HANSEN: Something Sanjay
has helped develop at MIT
is the MicroMasters
program, which
makes it possible for people
from all over the world
to earn professional and
academic credentials for MIT
courses they take
online, credentials
that can be applied
toward degrees at MIT
and other institutions
of higher learning.
SANJAY SARMA: The
MicroMasters gets
rid of the winnowing function.
So let me explain.
So how does a
master's program work?
You admit someone based on
letters of recommendations
and scores, letters from people
you probably have never met,
scores from universities
you haven't visited
or you don't know.
Admissions-- it's a
winnowing function.
It's based on such
sparse information.
What we do with the MicroMasters
is there is no admissions.
All comers are welcome.
It's online.
The incremental cost of
adding a student is very low.
Come on in.
Take the courses.
Finish up.
Take the proctored exam.
It's not easy.
It's difficult.
When you finish, you
have a MicroMasters.
And oh, by the way,
if you did really well
and you get into school, we'll
give you a credit for it.
So we've reversed the funnel.
So that's what the
MicroMasters is.
SARAH HANSEN: Sanjay
has been on this path
of making educational
materials more
accessible on a large
scale for over 20 years.
So I asked him
what advice he has
for other educators about
how to engage with Grasp
and how to get involved
with scaling education.
SANJAY SARMA: What I suggest
educators do is, first of all,
write down a wish list of
what they would like to do,
what they would like to see in
the education system, how they
do it differently, and how
it maps to how they taught
their own kids or
how they learned
and how a good
teacher inspired them.
I was involved a little bit in
the creation of OpenCourseWare
20 years ago.
And when I was doing my dynamics
lectures, a colleague said,
hey, can I make recordings
because I'm picking up
your course and I want
to see how-- the approach
you take to teach it?
And so when I made
the recordings,
I called up OpenCourseWare
and I said, look,
if it's useful to you,
I'd like to put them up,
for what it's worth, because
I teach dynamics differently.
And one thing led to another
and it just went up there.
And I actually think that to
un-self-consciously just share
yourself is something-- there's
something liberating about it,
frankly.
And I recommend that others try.
Just make a YouTube
video of yourself
doing something you love.
Put it up.
And I'm sure it will
be of value to others.
SARAH HANSEN: Making
ourselves vulnerable
can lead to something of
great value for others.
It's something we see every
day here at MIT OpenCourseWare.
So we'd like to say a huge thank
you to Sanjay Sarma and all
of the MIT faculty who not only
share their teaching materials,
but also share how they
teach through interviews
on our website and through
podcast episodes like this one.
You can find Sanjay Sarma's
teaching materials on our MIT
OpenCourseWare website.
You can also pick
up a copy of Grasp
at your local
library or bookshop.
Some other books he suggests
educators pair with Grasp
are Make It Stick and Peak:
The Science of Expertise.
And be sure to check
out Sanjay's latest
book, Workforce Education: A
New Roadmap, from MIT Press.
Thank you so much for listening.
Until next time, signing off
from Cambridge, Massachusetts,
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen,
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
Chalk Radio's producers
include myself, Brett Paci
and Dave Lishansky.
Scriptwriting assistance
from Nidhi Shastri.
Show notes for this episode
were written by Peter Chipman.
We're funded by MIT Open
Learning and supporters
like you.